hmm
hello everybody
anybody is out there hopefully
have a live stream with james altucher
who's become somewhat famous perhaps
infamous
anybody is out there hopefully
and while we're waiting for james i want
to
first begin by reading some of the
uh controversy i want to share the
controversy teach the controversy
and that will hopefully segue into
the moment when james gets on the line
with us
the um the reason that we're chatting
with james today
has to do with this very interesting
article very provocative
article that he posted
on linkedin facebook and all over the
place and on his blog
about a week and a half ago uh for which
he received
the whirlwind he reaped the whirlwind
and it was interesting to me because
james has always told me
the most important thing is to be honest
and courageous
and publish things even when you're
scared to publish things don't be
don't be afraid to go live with
something as i'm doing now
because it is usually a sign when you're
nervous
that you're on the right track that
you're doing something good that you're
not doing it for likes and clicks and
hearts and whatever else
that he recommends and i started to do
this
um as well based on his information and
based on his suggestion
uh um let me just put this out
with james sure there we go
just so people can follow the stream
um hi out there everybody hey peter
uh it's great to see you guys uh what
james recommends is that that's a sign
that's your inner voice telling you
you're on the right track
when you're scared to publish something
i've had people on that i disagree
with vehemently when it comes to
politics or it comes to their
uh their views on certain things
scientifically
even otherwise and i think the thing to
do in that case
is to separate the personal from the
professional or from the idea
and i think when you do that it makes
for deep connections with the people who
will resonate with your ideas and people
like people that are courageous they
don't like
people that take popular opinions and
maintain the status quo and of course
it's okay to
disagree with things that people like
james will say
but uh in the end i think that some of
the attacks especially this attack that
james received yesterday which
precipitated this
conversation that i hope to have with
james if he
beams in from florida was actually
precipitated by
an ad hominem you know somewhat funny
op-ed in the new york times by none
other than jerry seinfeld
and that really surprised me because i
know that they
personally know each other and the the
vehemence the derision the anger in
jerry seinfeld's article
kind of uh belied the underlying
sentiment
that i think he was attempting to say
and it got picked up by the new york
post
and then bill de blasio the mayor of new
york city
i won't say what i think about him
currently again i try not to be
political
on the show um uh suffice to say let me
give my bona fides i was born in new
york
i grew up in new york i went to all
schooling up until college
in new york until i went to case western
and i'd never been
west of pennsylvania pretty much until i
went to
uh i went to college i've spent my whole
life there
um i love new york city i know james
loves new york city he was born in new
jersey
i was actually born in new york uh in a
hospital in new york and then came to
um move to new york city where he spent
most of his life
and he's i think he's 52 now and
he has a comedy club there his kids
lived there
he went to school not far away he he
went to
um has had tremendous numbers of
businesses there he was there on 9 11.
he lived two or three blocks away from
ground zero
he's had a love relationship with new
york city and it's not even
love hate now but he sees some
uh interesting uh prospects on the
horizon that he
is worried about and i can't say i
disagree with them
so if you don't know i'll put the i'll
put i already put or maybe i'll put this
in the link
in the video chat right now so you guys
can tune in
so the first link i'm going to put in is
a um
is a link to um the article
in linkedin that james published and
this has to do with
um with the new york city
um forecast that he's making that caused
so much
backlash attention etc to
um uh to come to james and including
as i said with uh even uh folks like
chat right now so you guys can use
bill de blasio and others so here's the
linkedin article i'll link that there
and then i'll put the seinfeld response
which i think even for jerry was over
the top
um but i want to get uh james reaction
and it's also a study on how you handle
this kind of criticism
especially when you put things out into
the world
and you have no control over how they're
going to be reacting to
and i will want to discuss with james
how
um how he uh
takes this in comparison to how someone
like noam chomsky who also was the
victim of a
of a vicious leveling of attacks and the
two of them couldn't be more different
in a lot of ways
but the attacks that chomsky got for
signing on to a letter
in uh where was it um
one of you guys will tell me where it
was i can't harper's magazine that's
right
and uh he signed on and then people like
jk rowling who
for some reason is incredibly
controversial i know
some of you will probably correct me and
tell me that i'm a fool for not knowing
or understanding why but
everybody you know is like not only is
everybody famous for 15 minutes everyone
will have
uh derision leveled at them for 15
minutes so
uh it's it's really quite quite
frustrating james is a friend
uh he inspires me to do better as a
podcaster he's got
literally probably 10 000 hours just
worth of interviews with people
personalities online plus he's been on
millions of podcasts himself
and if you know the anders ericsson or
the malc made famous by malcolm gladwell
uh i really urge you to look into what
james does because he's got that 10 000
hours that's you know
apocryphally called the minimum number
to achieve mastery in a subject whether
that's being a pilot
you know pilots with ten thousand hours
are fairly rare and they're quite
uh talented takes a lot of ability skill
wisdom
and most importantly experience to get
to a level of proficiency where you can
live long enough to fly for 10 000 hours
i have less than half of that but i'm
working my way up
and doing so and hopefully someday i
will be a master by that definition
but james is a master podcaster and he
literally has been doing this since
the early 2000s when podcasting became a
thing
and he's influenced many people he's had
many shows of his own he's had shows
with people like
stephen dubner from freakonomics he's
done
where i met him at tedx talk in san
diego in 2014
and he has one of the best-selling books
of all time in the self-help
help genre called choose yourself and
that's kind of the theme
that he lives in his life where he is
not afraid
to take positions to look after his
interests first and then if people go
along with him
he will um you know he'll take people
along for the ride and
and share his talents his ideas he gives
away
literally you know tens and tens of
ideas a week away to people for
businesses
for investments and i want to talk to
him about that uh because i
think it gives him uh credibility you
can make predictions anybody can make
predictions
uh but uh but it's hard to you know kind
of stick your neck out as consistently
and not be fearful and that's one of the
things i most respect about him
you imagine you know jerry seinfeld is
probably the most popular comedian alive
today i mean he's not
been cancelled uh himself he you know he
avoids certain situations where he
claims he would get canceled
college campuses etc and so um
can you imagine someone with tens of
millions of followers fans
most popular show in the history of
television um
billionaire uh connected deeply in
hollywood you mentioned if he wrote an
op-ed
and he called you a putts which you know
this is actually not rated for kids but
it's a derisive term for a certain
appendage uh on the male human body
so i think it's uh it's it would be
quite terrifying and
you know i i i want to know how did
somebody react to that when such a thing
happens and
and and like can you just imagine that i
i wouldn't like it if if someone you
know
in my social circle said that about me
in the in the local
you know school newspaper let alone uh
on the op-ed section
of the new york times the paper of
record and literally it's been picked up
around the world you know jerry seinfeld
comes out and smashes
you know cowardly blah blah blah and
it's um
it really it it hurt me because i have
so much respect for james
i respect jerry i think he's funny uh
they're two totally different
personalities
jerry obviously extremely successful um
a very very creative mind
but james is is also i mean it's a guy
who is a computer scientist went to
cornell carnegie mellon
did serious computer science uh created
some of the first websites in history
for
top commer uh commercial enterprises
like amex
hbo um etc was early investor made tens
of millions of dollars
and lost tens of millions of dollars and
is just completely candid
and as he says he spills his guts about
what he has experienced
and he does so you know as we pilots say
you can't really afford to
to make mistakes all the mistakes that
can be made so you must learn from the
mistakes of other pilots or else you
won't live long enough to make them all
yourself
he does these things in part uh to
transfer his wisdom and his knowledge
about how
he has handled things including firing
rejection
relationship collapse divorce he's been
married three times
um you know not everything about james
is worthy of emulation
uh certainly according to my wife um who
also enjoys his
his work and his comedy but um but i
think it's really
it's really interesting i hope he'll
join soon if not i'll continue reading
until he does he you know he's got
he's just been interviewed on all these
uh all these
big name radio shows so let me let me
just first start off writing up uh
reading james writing in linkedin i
linked it in the chat i'll put it in the
text description later on it says i love
new york city when i first moved to
new york city it was a dream every
corner was like a theater production
happening right in front of me so much
personality so many stories
every subculture i love was in new york
city i could play chess all day at night
i could go to comedy clubs i could start
any type of business i could meet people
i had family i had friends opportunities
no matter what happened to me new york
city was a net i could fall back on and
bounce up
now it's completely dead but new york
city always bounces back
no not this time but new york city is
the center of the financial universe
opportunities will flourish here again
not this time new york city has
experienced worse no it hasn't
a facebook group formed a few weeks ago
that was for people that were planning a
move and wanted others to talk and ask
advice from
within two or three days it had about 10
000 members and i actually remember when
james was helping participate and start
that facebook group it wasn't to
encourage mass migration you know he's
he's politically an atheist i would say
or an agnostic he really he doesn't even
vote
except in mayoral and local elections uh
just is just an aside
but he um you know he's he's an
apolitical animal
but he sees things through a uh through
i think a very rational lens
and what's so surprising to me is when
you see someone like seinfeld reacting
just to the paragraphs i read i mean he
mocks james for
oh he he misses playing chess i mean
that's literally
one of uh jerry's comments so he says
um uh and it's just very vicious i mean
it's very surprising
you have to check out these links um see
he talks about how bad it was
in the beginning when he moved to new
york city he says the exact same things
as james
and then he says listening to james go
on this is jerry now
i used to play chess all day i could
meet people i could start any type of
business wipe your tears
wipe your butt and pull it together
uh it's not even that funny the thing
that really struck me about
jerry's article is that in contra
distinction to james's
or jerry's op-ed i mean both of them are
like opinion they're not like they're
meticulously researched articles that
we're going to put in a journal
somewhere
uh but here's here's james talking this
creed decor cry from the heart
because he loves new york here's jerry
acting as the
defender of the virtue of this of this
island of the manhattans
as melville called it and then he mocks
all these other people he says
um and james says this is jerry writing
he says james says he knows many people
have left new york from maine vermont
tennessee and indiana
i've been to all these places many many
many times over many decades
and with all due respect and affection
are you kidding me
well that's completely offensive
you know by the way whenever somebody
says you know don't take this the wrong
way
or i really shouldn't say this but
they're about to say something that they
really believe
and that's really obnoxious and awful
but they're trying to give it some sort
of
intellectual psychological cover so that
they can plausibly deny it later on
how could you say it's about vermont
tennessee and indiana those are some of
my favorite places on earth
maine is like a is a lovely place okay
so does it have
you know 80 000 restaurants no but what
makes new york so special
the culture etc is exactly what james is
talking about
being affected and afflicted by the
coronavirus so i think it's um
it's uh first of all the mockery of
middle america
and in particular he reserves a special
vitriol uh jerry seinfeld does
for florida basically saying you you
can't do you can do it from miami
florida is you deserve florida basically
completely mocking florida as well
and i think you know it gives a bad name
uh to
kind of the traditional stereotype of
people from new york
you know i'm a new yorker and um
and just thinking about you know how you
can mock this like i know personally
an extremely wealthy person who just
moved from los angeles it's not like
uh california is so doing so much better
than new york it's new york has a higher
population density as a city it has more
reliance on public transportation
subways it's better than la does i know
an extremely wealthy person who just
moved from la
to nashville tennessee and he loves it
he totally loves it this is a guy whose
kids are in hollywood productions he's
in hollywood productions
why did he leave la doesn't have enough
culture the culture of new york you got
to be kidding me
it has even more now because we can go
outside
in the warm temperatures and and
actually enjoy
enjoy outdoor dining etc yeah you can do
that in new york for a little while
i don't know how good it's going to be
come you know december 1st or
next year when they open broadway all
these things are closed down and
james has a point that this is a new
chapter in new york and it's not like
anything else
so continuing with james's article sorry
to keep going back and forth
but i think it's important for me to
kind of give my perspective the first
part was this derision
and superiority the smugness of seinfeld
by the way it's true
james wrote a retort to jerry and
twitter
which was kind of funny he's like yeah
it's great for you you're and jerry
writes oh i'm on long island right as we
speak
yeah jerry's on long island you know
he's not in like bayshore
or you know he's not in in uh the the
five towns or wherever he
he's he's not on fire island he's on
east hampton i've i've seen his
his mansion on east hampton it is not
like uh
sheltering in place for most of us so
you know jerry the sanctimony is kind of
um sheltering too
um there's a difference between
sheltering on you know shelter island uh
and and people that are you know really
my friends that live in manhattan
my my family that lives in manhattan
they feel under siege
even still and you know they're still so
glad and so appreciative of the
healthcare workers that are taking care
of everybody
but the bottom line is it feels much
more like you know kind of the blitz of
london or something like that this is
according to i have
hundreds of family and friends from
there i went to high school there
i went to elementary school there i grew
up there james did too
so why does he say the most important
reasons to move to new york city let's
say you're going to move to new york
city right now
there will be business opportunities
there's culture there's food and
friends but of course you know if you
have friends around the country unlike
you know potentially jerry seinfeld
although jerry spends a lot of time out
here in l.a so
you know he's he's or you know it's sort
of nice for him to be able to
be bicoastal in that sense and he does
has more opportunities than
than you know james or or someone else
might have
uh you know it helps to have a you know
your own jet
and um and a stockpile of porsches to
get yourself around
as jerry uh certainly does um but
uh but nevertheless let's look at these
three opportunities let's just look at
them dispassionately rationally like
scientists
okay so business is is james correct
midtown manhattan the center of business
in new york city is empty
even though people can go back to work
famous office buildings like time life
skyscraper are still 90
empty businesses realize they don't need
their employees at the office this is
totally true
um he later goes on and talks about
education of course new york city is a
capital of education
there's you know half a dozen or more
world-class universities there
many of which have collaborators friends
of mine are there colombia
hunter college uh city college uh nyu
these are some of the best institutions
in the world and they're not holding in
person classes
as most of our universities are not um
what would allow this
as compared to a couple of you know
years ago or even a year ago
and he really puts it down to zoom now
jerry makes the point that nobody likes
zoom but i have a feeling that
you know jerry doesn't spend quite as
many hours on telecons on zoom than i do
uh zoom has been a live chat look i'm
doing this live stream via zoom without
zoom
a year ago zoom didn't have the
capability to do this didn't have the
bandwidth to do this
it was buggy and um and had all sorts of
other
glitches i couldn't do it on facetime or
you could do it on skype
but it was kind of a pain to set up
auxiliary software to do that
um but uh getting back to james's main
thrust is you know the advent of
bandwidth and tools like zoom
are allowing entire universities to go
back uh virtually
not in person or hybrid some are going
back partially
some are going back fully uh uh using
zoom
and some some are trying to open but
most of them are closing down
it appears we uh i don't fully know what
our situation is going to be like here
in san diego just
for your information i think it's a
little bit influx we don't start until
late september
so we have a month to make final
decisions
but um i would not doubt that we're not
going to be in person
um i think we we're likely to be a
virtual all meetings are basically
virtual my laboratory i'm only allowed
to have a few people in there at a time
socially distanced um etc so it's it's
it's a very different world than
oh we're just going to bounce back and
like nothing ever happened
okay continuing with james's uh piece in
linkedin
so he's been living there for you know
his whole life 30 years straight
for 10 years 15 years uh and he's
quoting from people that have been there
uh for even longer or as long as he has
since the 1970s when
uh the new york city was bankrupt and it
was a crime capital
of the country and a place like times
square which is like a glitzy or was a
glitzy
almost like shopping mall i didn't even
recognize it the last time i was there
one of my my publisher
norton is not far away from times square
i go and visit them there and it was
like
my parents wouldn't let me go near times
square when i was a kid
now it's like you can't afford to go
there because it's so nice
there's not these uh you know uh x-rated
movie theaters and drug dealers and and
crime everywhere
looting uh rioting whatever um
has uh taken its toll uh james talks
about and then he talks about
the places where people are going which
seinfeld you know can
conveniently omit some of them but he
includes you know tennessee
maine uh and jerry's james got this
uh chart that shows the popular 10 most
popular destinations
for percentage of people that are
leaving new york city and this is from
some other stores redfin the real estate
company
the number one destination is atlanta
georgia uh jerry doesn't mention oh well
one derisively why are you going to
atlanta brian i'm really
really sorry oh hey james how are you
doing um let me
let me get this working all right i just
been reading your article
i've been reading your linkedin article
james to the audience
uh we're live by the way we're live so
no no oh my gosh i'm really sorry
your hands to yourself no i think it's
okay i think my both of my viewers have
been watching for a while
uh de blasio so i was late on another
podcast and then
mayor de blasio was just referring to me
live
on a press conference which is just
insane that i'm i'm
i'm not i think my article is not that
important
compared to many of the issues that my
article brings up
yes so i think yeah related my article
to being an issue
i'm not creating the problem the article
is not creating the problem the article
is pointing out
the problem and even de blasio's like oh
this person
wants to leave and give up on the city
i i said no such thing of course i just
i point out the facts that are
undeniable
but and i talk about my own love for the
city
and everybody went insane on that i know
i know but i really apologize i don't
like being like no no no no i've been
i've actually gave me a great chance to
share some of my thoughts and not waste
your valuable time can you just point
the camera a little more at your face
james
your lower mouth your lower third of
your of your face is getting cut out
there you go hi
so um uh yeah so we're live uh there's
there's a bunch of people on but um
but the first the only the first thing i
want to say is that you have tremendous
courage
and you're a hilarious guy and i learn a
lot from you comedically
as a podcaster as a father not as a
husband
because you know third time's a charm
for you i'm hoping the first time will
work out for me
but judy gloom told me third time's a
charm also so
you know judy bloom defined our
childhood that's right
without her i wouldn't i wouldn't become
a man right i wouldn't know what to do
when i got my period the first time
exactly that was uh that was i haven't
gotten it since i have not gotten it
since so
um but that might have been a body blow
for my older brother um
so james first of all thank you so much
for your courage um i always tell you
you've got the rarest human trait which
is courage because this withering i mean
imagine like if i told you two weeks ago
you're gonna wake up
one of the most famous human beings
who's ever lived a billionaire
is going to be besieging you attacking
you not for something you did you didn't
do anything
uh and and the mayor of the largest city
in america would be attacking you
assailing you criticizing you i mean
you thought 2020 was a simulation before
where's your mind out right now
it's so funny you bring up the
simulation thing because
first off i will i mean the article was
already
creating way i wrote the article a week
and a half ago you know our title is new
york city is dead forever here's why
and i really wanted it to be a wake-up
call these
this is my city too i was born in this
city i've
lived in it i've lived here all through
the pandemic but i was also living right
next to ground zero on 9 11.
i was living on wall street during the
financial collapse
and i'm worried and here's the issues
these are facts these issues they're
they're facts i'm not making
i didn't create them i'm reporting them
and not quite as a reporter but as
someone who's
a concerned lifelong new yorker and
it got a lot of attention last week you
know people wrote articles
like this guy could just drop dead you
know i hope he
jumps in the water with a lead lifesaver
um this guy you i was people would send
me entire videos you should be hung
and i was getting some a lot of hate but
also
a lot of people were saying yeah you
know people were privately messaging me
like yeah
you know there's issues we left new york
or this is why we're moving to
memphis tennessee or whatever and my
point was too
is that opportunity now the good side of
this is opportunity now
might be decentralized throughout the
whole country
we live in a country built on
innovationism
let's use that word instead of
capitalism so innovationism our ability
for each generation to to innovate and
this might mean that the entire country
now will
innovation will be dispersed from san
francisco la
new york city and every city now could
could
be a source of innovation but new york
city is going to have
these economic issues and also i don't
know what to do about them like they're
really
important huge issues and again
they're facts they're not my opinion and
and then everybody went crazy and that
was last week so then monday
i figure okay it's it's died down now
everything's gonna be okay
i was a little stressed out because it's
not
i usually get some hate you know you're
not really writing anything interesting
if there's not a little bit of
controversy yeah um because then you're
not stating a new opinion
but then i wake up and i saw i woke up
and i saw right when somebody texted me
hey hey you putts what's going on and
i'm like
why is this woman i hardly ever speak to
calling me a putts like
what i've never been called that before
and then apparently there was a reason
jerry seinfeld in the new york times
had singled me out for some reason and
was saying
basically the worst he was eviscerating
me like you know he's
he's a funny guy so yeah i said it
wasn't funny it was ad hominem which is
not
yeah no right he he i don't know what he
was doing like and i don't i still don't
know why really he was
tearing me apart and he was and it was
because of the article but he wasn't
addressing
he didn't address the fact that look
thousand
up to 30 to 40 to 50 of restaurants in
new york city
might be shut down forever yeah broadway
is might might be shut like who's gonna
invest in the next broadway production
where's broadway going it might be
going outdoors james it's gonna be on
broadway literally you're going to be on
right which will be impossible because
of the way broadway is
structured with unions but then what
happens to the whole
economy around broadway the restaurants
the hotels the tourism
you know what happens to commercial real
estate when everybody goes remote
and why are they going to go remote well
bandwidth now you and i were talking at
30 40 megabits
per second whereas in 2008 it was only 2
megabits per second so now we can do
this
remote and every company has realized
that and it turns out remote
actually there's studies on this remote
is more productive and it's cost savings
so what just happens to new york city
tax revenues
meanwhile deficits are going up so
and and look it's not me saying this i
know blasio is
is firing 22 000 workers on august 31st
he's firing emts
teachers mta workers police garbage
collectors
so what's gonna happen just gonna be
garbage all over the streets and
people's lives are gonna be in danger
and i just point this all out jerry
seinfeld
could have helped you know he's in a
strong position of influence much more
influential than me
maybe he could have pointed to some
solutions or or
he could have written hey maybe we need
some sort of bailout or maybe we need
people to gather together and and help
the community
instead he just he spent almost the
entire article like ninety-five percent
of it attacking me personally and
five percent saying new york's got grit
and
yeah all these amorphous things the
other thing james i pointed out
uh sorry to interrupt is that the
absolute
derision that he has for anyone who's
not in new york
and you know i i was saying to my
listeners before you got on
you know like jerry's writing this from
a mansion which i
personally have seen that has you know a
phalanx of porsches out in front of it
from the 1950s to today
uh you know next to a private jet so he
says i'm a new i'm unlocked i have also
have a place on long island
you know like it's in bay shores you
know it's he's in like amagansett or
east hampton i forget which one but the
derision
that he has for florida for maine for
vermont for 10 anywhere that's
it's like that new yorker cartoon where
they show like the new yorkers view of
the world
and look uh jerry you james
me we're all new york jews i thought you
know seinfeld was not jewish enough you
know i used to say that
uh but look this is this is not a good
look i mean saying like
are you kidding me like tennessee i just
speaking
i know a multi-multi-millionaire whose
kids are in hollywood they're in
i can't tell you which production they
make tons of money on on movies and so
forth
um and you know child actors and they're
pampered they were living in
in florida in los angeles i called them
last week how you doing we should get
together for
for dinner sometimes uh that'll be hard
because i'm in nashville
i'm like what the heck you're in
nashville he's like yeah i couldn't take
it anymore
and i'm like la has much more going for
it right now
because of our temperature proximity to
the pacific
uh lack of coronavirus patients compared
to new york city unfortunately it was
you know you and i
and jerry are all lifelong new yorkers
at heart but um
he moved and he's a new yorker and he
but he moved from la to nashville
wha what's wrong with nashville i mean
he said he got seven times the house
that he was living in
you know in hollywood he got uh you know
he's got immediately he'd do his work
remote over i was talking to him over
zoom he's a you know he's doing this and
he's setting up his kids can do
voice-overs and stuff for disney
using zoom that's what they're doing and
to have this vitriol for people
you know in tennessee you know this guy
can run rings
and and not to mention the fact that
you're doing comedy still from stand-up
new york but you're doing it outside
how are you going to keep doing that in
january i mean this has gotten
ridiculous but the ad hominem attack i
the last thing i'll say before you
continue is it reminded me of this
conversation i had with noam chomsky you
remember i was asking you for advice
should i publish this thing
i was kind of nervous because i don't
agree with him on much politically
but you were like that's precisely the
reason you have to publish this you nee
you encourage me to have courage and
that was the i call that the all toucher
assay you know when you have when you
have this nagging tingling doubt
should i do this should i put make the
push the post button that's exactly when
you have to get over the hurdle go
through the tunnel
and push that button and um and when i
was talking to gnome there was a point
in the conversation where it's just
funny like he has his dog coming
and his dog is like barking his head off
and i'm like god how am i going to talk
to this 92 year old guy
you know born 10 years to the day before
pearl harbor or whatever
and the dog's barking and i'm like numb
would you mind you know
the dog's linguistics are you know kind
of challenging me you mind putting a
muzzle on i was just joking or whatever
and people were like yelling at me and
then i said they were like how could you
tell gnome's dog to say
i said uh there's a famous quote from
like epictetus or you know ryan holloway
could tell us who it is but
the quote is the dog barks at that which
it does not understand
and i kept thinking that when i read uh
jerry's op-ed
he's just barking there's nothing there
he doesn't understand it
i mean his main point was that
people are this this guy meaning me is
just
i wouldn't want to be in a war with him
like he's just giving up
and look i don't recall jerry being a
vietnam vet or a gulf war vet or
anything but i don't know
i would want to see the cola wars he
served proudly in the cold wars
right and and i i
i would want to be with someone who
could accurately assess the situation
and start to come up with
solutions other than just we've gotta
grit and storm
the front lines like which is look i'm a
new yorker i'm still a new yorker my
kids go to school in new york i own a
comedy club in new york
um i haven't been you know jerry's been
in and i don't i don't mean to say
anything but he criticized me on this i
was in new york from march through
july he was in he's been in the hampton
since
march and like you said in a castle
like um envious of his situation and
i don't understand why what and i can
understand
there was a lot of anger from people who
maybe didn't understand that i was
trying to point
do a wake-up call and point out problems
and people are scared people are scared
their real estate's gonna go to zero
they're scared their jobs are gonna be
lost
and i'm trying to say a third you know
there's again
even the new york times says that a
third of small businesses in new york
city might not
ever come back and you know this is a
scary thing so
yes i didn't expect people to direct
their anger
at me but it happened whatever
but i don't know what his agenda was or
why he did it or
he's a smart guy i'm not questioning
that i don't i just don't
understand it like okay well jerry what
how does grit help when
every uh uh restaurant goes out of
business how does grit you know
some people are saying if if if indoor
dining is closed through the winter
90 of restaurants might go out of
business yeah what what jerry what's
what's gonna happen then you
you tell us like yeah the only thing i
see doing is
encouraging people to wear masks like
people have this
feel the need to actually do something
humans are you know animus you know an
animal that likes to do something right
and so putting on a mask and you know
there's differing uh you know kind of
philosophy some resisted some don't but
the point is the mask
is something that you can do actively um
tell me you know when you have five kids
and and you have to educate them and
you've got one computer not like jerry
you know presumably
uh and and et cetera and they're all
fighting over it and they have to be
quiet and you've got one pair of
headphones and they got six zoom cl
it is a nightmare and there's never been
911
you could go to i went down to 911
ground zero my my cousin went down there
as it was happening and he was just
trying to help
yeah you were right next to it um when
that happened and
um you could do something and people did
and their hearts poured out
what do you do now there's you know
people use this metaphor of the the
virus we're in a war against the
we're not there there's no war there's
no enemy that you can fight you know
like all of a sudden we're all gonna
become epidemiologists and molecular
biologists i mean
that's the that's what we're left with
but the fact that he
he just like it was kind of like this um
i felt it was a little pandering
you know he's kind of like new york is
going to be there you know kind of like
the billy joel
anthem after 9 11. or you know it's kind
of like now we're going to solidify and
it but
but the fact how does it feel that you
know yeah this is this is targeting
around you
and it's not even targeting your ideas
because he's just like
everyone hates zoom okay so like i'm on
a lot more zoom than you are jerry i'm
sure
you know i used to joke i thought as an
astronomer i'd be on telescopes but i'm
on telecons
most of my life and for him to like you
know oh
zoom sucks okay so like when you have
your virtual 3d hologram you know
virtual presence you know are you still
gonna not you know
uh believe that that there's something
that's different qualitatively
and the other thing i'll say before you
go on james is you know he makes fun of
like he says
silicon valley do you know why people
live there the biggest tower
i believe west of manhattan is the
salesforce tower
in in san francisco do you know how long
it's going to be closed for like this
enormous building you know like nearly
the size of the of the
of one world trade center they're
closing it for at least they're saying
you don't have to come back to
salesforce you don't have to come back
to twitter
you don't have to come back to you can
have all my friends that are working at
google
in la in the bay area they're working
from home they're
it's not affecting them as much as as
jerry might think they were
because they don't have the in-person uh
uh um
you know energy as he calls it so what
do you make of that like what
how can yeah you know just on that point
though
you know it's interesting he says people
don't want to do that well a
i haven't found that to be true most
people i speak to
yes sometimes they like going into the
office
and sometimes they don't but many people
don't like going into a cubicle
and just hanging out with their cubicle
mates all day long
i always ask people are you going to go
to the funeral of your cubicle mate like
is that
are you guys lifelong friends i don't
even like to go to the bathroom with
half of them
right exactly and and and but it's but
even besides that
it's not the individual's choice
unfortunately like
corporations have many issues a they
don't know what the liability
issues are around the virus so no laws
have been
set there are liability issues they
don't know if someone gets sick while
they're coming
to work uh and being in a conference
room meeting with someone coughing is
the does the company get
they don't know so they want people to
work remote then there are many studies
that show that people are simply
more productive working remotely not for
every job but for most jobs
now people say well you know you know
new york's not like detroit
where detroit of course is in shambles
and they're very correct
detroit was actually hard to have you
can't have people work remote
in detroit because they were making cars
you have to be uh
in the factory making the car in new
york the main industries are finance and
media and tech and those are all
industries of course you could work
remote particularly now that we have
zoom
so companies instead of renting
expensive
real estate in new york can say okay
we're gonna go downsize from
seven floors to one floor and we'll send
everybody remote and citigroup jp morgan
you mentioned google many hundreds of
companies are doing this
and people are fine like i know people
all over the country now one friend of
mine just moved i mentioned in the
article we just moved to phoenix
and he was in here in in the office
every day until this pandemic now
he's never gonna have to go back to the
office again he's in phoenix
salaries stayed the same but the company
reduced
their floor space every company is doing
this
and but that has consequences new york
city real estate goes down
restaurants have less customers the hot
dog stand
outside the bodega the newspaper guy the
transit system the subways the buses the
trains uh
and then again broadway the entire
ecosystem around that
uh restaurants the entire ecosystem
around the restaurant industry or this
you know there's two quarter million
small businesses in new york that
that may never you know 30 of them may
never open again as is
you know some estimates quoted in the
new york times so
i don't i i think there are big problems
and then when you
again when you have deficits this high
and tax revenues that could get cut in
half
we haven't even seen the effects of it
but we have seen the effects of sales
taxes going down and that's why de
blasio
who was just live making fun of me on tv
he is on august 31st he has to cut
according to a city spokesperson he has
to cut 22 000 jobs including emts
garbage collectors police and so on
so that's what starts to happen in a
city
in new york's situation unless there's
it's not like this utopia where all of a
sudden rents are cheap and young people
and artists can move in
bad things happen first to get to that
point that point doesn't happen
for 20 years or ever that's right
and and again it could be the case that
opportunity gets dispersed
the young up and coming you know let's
say we live in this
innovationist culture like let's not
call it capitalist for a second let's
call it
innovationist so innovationists are
usually
young people who move to san francisco
la new york city they're going to strike
out on their own and they're going to
make it big if i can make it here i can
make it anywhere
well now they can make it big in
nashville in memphis in st
louis in denver in dallas and austin in
miami
they don't have to be in new york la or
san francisco anymore they can make
friends in these cities they can make
industries careers they can move to
phoenix and work on wall street
so the world's a different place and so
again i'm not
sure why he you know
not to bring it back to jerry seinfeld's
personal attack on me but i don't know
why he did that
instead of addressing real issues
the thing is you know it's like i guess
i missed jerry's newsletter where he
has this great track record of
forecasting i i compiled a short list of
things that you've been
dead spot on i call you you know just on
the money james so
you called bitcoin back in 2010
i believe was the first time you started
like what the hell is he talking about
you know i've been following you for
stalking i'm following you for 20 years
or what 15 years we spoke together a
tedx san diego you called bitcoin when
it was like a penny
you charged uh you know like one bitcoin
for copies of your book
which people in 2013 i built probably
the first e-commerce store
uh for bitcoin i only sold my book in it
so i was able to
claim i was the best selling author on
bitcoin only ever
yeah and you took took um you know very
courageous stance back in the early days
of amazon self-publishing
you uh you called the apple to be the
first company across 1 trillion
called the first time apple across 2
trillion you called the south sea bubble
you called the tulip mania i mean you've
been right so many times james like
what's jerry's record of social societal
prognostication well i would say he was
a genius and i will uh here's where
and this is more of a larry david thing
but let's combine them together for a
second yeah
you know a show about nothing
was kind of a show where you learn
nothing was kind of an innovation
in entertainment and media you know in
mainstream media entertainment uh and
but it wasn't just that where they
really were innovative with seinfeld was
they gave
each main character obviously there were
four main characters you know kramer and
george and and
elaine and and jerry in every episode
each character had a storyline
that all came together at the end no
other sitcom had done that before
and i think that was really larry
david's innovation he didn't want
just as a leader which most people don't
think of larry david as an example of
leadership but he really is
yeah as a leader he knew he didn't want
any of his main
stars who were becoming celebrities to
be just sitting around for an entire
episode so he made sure every episode
included all of them
and then another innovation was he knew
that he needed a constant
um feeding of new york city stories that
he was going to run out eventually
so he would fire the whole writing staff
every year and bring in new
from what i understand maybe not 100 but
like 90 he'd fire the whole writing
staff and bring in
new new york city writers to tell new
stories
and you know they he did a really good
job running the show and
uh you know and jerry continued that
after after larry left
and of course jerry was not only writing
and he was starring in it so
he they were innovative for what they
were and as a comedian
he's very innovative at taking the
commonplace and finding the unusual in
it
and so i will i will give him you know
full 100
credit he's the best in the world at
that but
in terms of social commentary uh
i don't know and again i'll
the only time i've ever seen him make
any social commentary was he wrote this
op-ed i've never seen him
write anything about anything before and
i've never seen an op-ed
so thoroughly just be a non-stop insult
before yeah it was almost i couldn't
tell whether to be funny or
stressed that it was about me like it
was funny in the sense that
this this is clearly a simulation now
i've proven it
and everybody is fake and this is just
about me
and i'm tired of this game you could
turn it off now
and at the same time i was getting
particularly in the morning i was
getting so much
hate that it was unbelievable like
and then everybody people i'd known 20
years ago who
who must have been holding on to some
tiny grudge
for me um you know suddenly piggybacked
because it was safe you know seinfeld's
anger and
it was just very disturbing then i wrote
a rebuttal and people
kind of even if they didn't read the
original article maybe they read the
rebuttal but by the end of the day i
felt like
people were starting to say oh jerry was
just
insulting this guy and this guy was just
presenting real rational issues
and by the way he's from new york also
born and bred
and and he had real things to say
yeah i was you know saying to uh to my
wife i was like why don't they
these two guys just settle it like new
yorkers have traditionally done
for hundreds of years like aaron burr
and alexander hamilton like
we should just have you know that's
that's a gentlemanly way to do it you
guys should just hash it out
but you know this this saying you know i
i wrote you on twitter i said you know
something like
you know this ratings gold like now
you're getting so much attention
um there's this there's a a book 1984
you you
surely know it animal farm another one
an animal form orwell talks about
benjamin the donkey
and he's like yeah i've got this great
tail and the tail keeps away the flies
and the pig's like oh you're so lucky
and benjamin's the donkey's like yeah
but i'd rather
not have the flies and not need the tail
it's like
where do you how do you come down on
that now like this is
it's hard to imagine that you're going
to get like this again a billionaire
super powerful hollywood guy um and i'm
talking about james altucher i know i'm
talking about jerry
uh and and then he's like and it's all
the all the plaudits online oh
just thank you jerry you know for
standing up to the to the like
this guy who's you know i mean it's true
you're not you're not at his level of of
wealth and fame and
but do you want it is that like were you
like oh great now i'm gonna kind of ride
the tide and surf the wake of jerry
seinfeld cracking up
uh you know also he doesn't mention you
but he mentions your club
i thought it was kind of weird you know
on one hand he's saying hey he's trash
the club
and by the way he's performed regularly
there he lives around when he's in
manhattan he's around the corner
i'm sure he is yeah the club he performs
at and he says you need to spruce it up
uh every comedy club in the world needs
to be spruced up i was just gonna say
that
i forgot about all those comedy clubs
where i eat off the floor you know
i dropped my my martini on the ground i
just lick it up because it's so clean
and
and modern i mean give me a break and by
the way the club is giving back to the
city like we're having
outdoor free shows they outdoor shows in
every single park this week no other
comedy club is doing that
and you know and all through this i mean
there was things that i've done all
through this pandemic to try to help the
community
and you know being you know
you know i don't really need to talk
about all of them but i know you have
you've done
go fun i'll say it for you i don't want
you to brag you've done gofundme things
people like no questions asked anything
for charity anything for business you've
been giving away
10 business ideas a week you know in the
beginning you were on live every day
just answering people's questions and
james you were partially like
a psychologist even for me i mean what
the hell does an astrophysicist have to
do
with some you know comedy club owner you
know but you're you know the way that
you
analyze the world in contra distinction
to someone like j and
again jerry put himself into this
position now we can criticize him
it's fair to say like what's your record
what's your level is it just for your
own virtue signaling what are you doing
this for
but i'm i won't i'll avoid that i
actually said in the beginning because
he says
like you know i say this in the best
possible way when he like slams middle
america which is totally offensive
um especially since we know both of us
know many people who are lifelong
new yorkers grew up there love it there
and came there for the very reasons you
talk about and he talks about
um and have left and gone to nashville
and atlanta and all the places you point
out from your
research driven article with data from
redfin with bandwidth
facts from from um online usage
and and his just pure emotion and i'm
looking at him saying well
you know james giving away so much uh
for free
and uh and i guess it's just like uh how
do you how do you
react to that because i think you were
doing it altruistically yeah now
i mean do you kind of like you you give
so much to yourself you're so vulnerable
i
i told the audience that before you came
out this man gives of himself
yeah i mean you have businesses and you
do that and and you're actually like
doing things like making
new improved tools for podcasting and
and and you're writing books
uh you kind of serve as a social pundit
that also is
has a very serious side you have a very
generous vulnerable serious side
that uh is incredibly endearing and
helps millions of people literally
millions of people
so i i you know i'll brag on your behalf
now you go on and say what you're going
to say about what else is going on in
new york city
well well i just you know
i was i've always been interested
right in the beginning of this pandemic
i said look this is an opportunity now
to show that the way a community
survives is when the community comes
together
and thinks about giving to each other
rich or poor you know big or small
regardless of race and i was hoping that
would happen
more instead of everybody just waiting
online for bailouts but also i'm glad
the bailouts
happened and hopefully more will happen
but
you can't again you you can't ignore the
problems new york's going through i mean
again you're right in the beginning of
the pandemic
a lot of the issue was what is
coronavirus
how long is this going to last the new
york times said there's 100 there's
going to be 140 million deaths around
the world is that true
like what's going to happen so i was
going through the mathematical
models and showing why some were wrong
some were right i was trying to explain
the math of what does exponential mean
in a real world environment it doesn't
mean
you double forever it means you it's
like a learning curve you double
and then you level off which that's a
pandemic curve is the same as looks like
a learning curve
and um you know and then when with the
economy i was having
federal reserve governors on i was
having on economists you know investors
congressmen and on several politicians
just to understand
okay this is what could happen and i was
worried if the pandemic lasts
for a certain period of time or the
lockdown and this is not
a statement on the the medicine of it or
anything it's just the lockdown is what
it is
now this is what would happen we could
have a problem
these problems are starting to come to
life now i've been
my the article was really a continuation
of what i've been saying all along that
these are some of the problems that
not only could exist but now they do
exist and
you know the hope i don't know if
there's hope or not but there's
certainly more and more
uncertainty and again for him
to ignore that i get it because he is
not going to face
the problems the workers are going to
face the problems
and the city is going to face the
problems and the people working for the
city and the people
working for the ecosystem around the
city
and you know the people who own who own
assets like real estate
in the city and again last week
i think i don't know what i could have
done differently like i don't know why
maybe because i told my own
personal story in there it got a little
bit more emotionally
charged so that created a cognitive bias
of some sort that was
aimed at me instead of aimed at the
issues
but then for seinfeld like why do you
think
seinfeld did that like why would he need
to do that
i think i think uh you know people again
they want to do
something so you know we have a role as
pilots we say you know don't just do
something stand there
or another adage from like the world war
two but now it doesn't work with you
know an apple watch but
used to be in case of emergency step one
on your checklist
wind your watch it's like people don't
like that it makes them feel very
uncomfortable they like to have you know
it's like inertia bias like they need to
feel like they're doing something or
else they feel helpless
and i think he's basically you know i
mean what is that you know
i think in a pandemic let's say an
asteroid is coming to the earth let's
get a comedian like
no it's not going to happen like that
that's not a top on your not not to say
he's not he does it probably gives
charity i actually don't know much about
what he does
um but i know he's his job is to do
uh is to make people entertain and to
make people laugh
i'm not even saying oh stay in your lane
but that's his skill set that's his
and he is a businessman he has a leader
uh et cetera i think you know combined
with a lot of good luck that he had that
he acknowledges
um but on on the other flip side it's
like um i think
people in that world that are purely
entertainers unlike you
like actresses like every year every
four years we get
um we get a you know statement from
hollywood actors and actresses on which
why we should vote for the democrat
who's running for president right it's
never like
we get the same thing from 70 nobel
prize winners every four years like
clockwork
this is why you should vote for the
democrat fine i'm not i don't talk
politics on the show as you know
but i think that there's you know even
for scientists like what we do when i
study the universe
it's significant on some level on some
meta-huge
level of thinking about the most
important things in the universe but on
a daily basis
you know we i saw a tweet from andrew
cuomo who's you know he actually i saw
tweet that he's attacking you now live
on
on
nbc no no he's not but it wouldn't
surprise me right yeah
so cuomo was like he's having a battle
with de blasio i think he's probably
staying away from it that's the only
thing that's protecting me
so he he's the enemy of my enemy is my
friend exactly right yeah
that's right so i looked at his tweet
it's like you know
retweet if you think scientists you know
that people should listen to scientists
not politicians
i'm like i'm a scientist i'm not going
to retweet that like i know a lot about
the early universe the big bang
different ways the universe could have
started um but you know
you're going to listen to me just
because i have you know i understand
differential geometry topology
uh early universe theory you're going to
listen to me about like like how we
should impact you know the continuation
the stimulus
no that's why we elected you buddy don't
try to push that off on me
um you know unless you're gonna start
paying me that that salary so i'm happy
to advise if gavin newsom my boss here
in california as a state employee
if he calls me up and he wants me to do
some mathematical modeling do some
physical testing in my lab and we
volunteered to do that early on
but come on listen to scientists because
but scientists want to do it
and i salute that it's a virtue to want
to be significant to have an impact to
save a life
you know etc so i think jerry wants to
like save the economy and do something
significant
because i think ultimately he knows deep
down inside
it's and it's not the job of an
entertainer to be significant to have
deep thoughts or to be a politician but
i sometimes think they have envy you
know like
someone said like you know physicists
have math envy you know because we can't
prove things the way mathematicians i
think sometimes
comedians have you know kind of
politician envy that's why you see
people like this hannah gadsby
you know like they'll have things and
they'll say you are not gonna laugh at
our show like
no i have enough things where i don't
laugh make me laugh
clown right well you know comedians have
a very
particular skill at walking into a room
and seeing what's
unusual in this room and
but you know so take someone like jon
stewart
jon stewart over decades honed that
particular muscle to
spot the unusual in the domain of news
and politics he got extremely good at
pointing out
what's unusual in the political system
in the news whatever whether you agree
with him or not
that was his skill set but you know
again jerry
you know he talks about pop-tarts tv
dinners
which people don't even eat i don't i
don't know if people if they even sell
tv
dinners anymore but he talks about these
other things that are kind of
he's an expert at the mundane i've
actually like i said before i never seen
him
comment on something you know
kurt not that he's not allowed to by the
way but again
just don't don't like you say it's it's
called an ad hoc and an attack where if
you don't have anything to say you just
attack
the the you you shoot the messenger it's
another way of saying shoot the
messenger instead of understand the
message
and i don't i i don't think he added to
the conversation and then of course de
blasio who's defending his record
is holding up his article saying thank
you
jerry who's this other guy and you know
well bill de blasio you're the one who's
gonna have to fire everyone and by the
way then it's happening to
la and san francisco uh next so
what's what's going to happen there's a
lot of uncertainty and and
when if we don't trust our leadership we
need to at least be aware of their flaws
so that we can
make decisions for ourselves yes new
york city people have
grit and americans have grit and
resilience
and and we have a sense of the the
frontier we can make it on our own to
to the frontier well now the frontier is
is also inside of ourselves because
we have to overcome this this fear about
this pandemic and this economic
unsecurity
i mean 55 million people in the country
at some point or other in the past five
minute
months filed for unemployment insurance
that's more than one out of three
workers it's
incredibly scary and you know you have
to be able to
jerry had to lay off three of his
butlers i mean yeah exactly
and you know and i'm sure maybe some
movies he was working on
i don't know i don't even know what he
does i i know he has a book coming out
in october so maybe
this was part of that campaign is oh
he was given some space in the op-ed so
he decided to focus it on
on this issue but since he's never
really written on
issues before he didn't he didn't have
that skill set i don't
even know but he certainly knows how to
tear someone apart like he has that
skill set
i know it's funny you said you know
finally you wrote some new material
right like i had to respond a little bit
so so i said yeah like i'm glad i
inspired
seinfeld to finally write some some new
jokes but
uh which which by the way a lot of
well-known comedians sent me messages
after that like
they didn't say it publicly where they
were like good job you know
yeah i thought it was great you know and
the other thing i want to say is another
thing i gleaned from noam chomsky and
again
thank you for really encouraging me to
do that it's like one of my most popular
videos now uh this interview that i was
reluctant to do
but you encouraged me you know go like
feed the feed the beast like the
uh the um what's the name joseph
campbell the hero's journey guy
he said um the hero of a thousand faces
said you know the cave that you fear to
enter
holds the treasure you are seeking and
you know when you said that not neo it's
a little overblown for noam chomsky you
know a guy
guys uh you know old enough to be my my
great grandfather but uh but a brilliant
person
and yet you know he was saying things
like when people which you got a lot of
criticism for which i think is a vector
that seinfeld is uh uh being influenced
by and that's how
a lot of the the outlets that picked up
your article were conservative fox news
glenn beck um and you got all that
attention for that
and people are criticizing you some guy
you know tens millions of followers say
you know you should be careful james
when before this is before pre-seinfeld
uh attack
and they're like you shouldn't have
written this because now all these idiot
rubes in middle america
are you know watching you on fox news
and then they're you know they're
having crackling and glee and it
reminded me what gnome said
to me when we had our interview i asked
him like how did you feel about the
backlash to this letter that you wrote
in harper's
he's like i found it entirely irrational
because people were responding to what
was done with the article after i wrote
it in particular
you know jk rowling now like i wouldn't
mind if jk rowling
you know has something to say about what
i wrote it doesn't it doesn't
by the by properties of time and
variance under reversal of the time
coordinate
you know like you don't know what
someone's going to do with your article
you didn't write it for fox news you
weren't like commissioned by rupert
murdoch here you go james write this
article and here's 10 million
you wrote it and it happened to be
picked up and it hit a nerve
now there's some shot in freudia i think
that there are you know people certainly
you know the people that are in middle
america that are being derided by the
seinfelds of the world
uh for living in nashville which is just
preposterous i mean i just got back from
you know a few days in
in jacksonville wyoming i was speaking i
was doing some stargazing
uh for my channel using enormous
telescopes really fun time
and it was very pleasant there too right
beautiful skies there
and it was very pleasant to be there and
i'm like you know i'm a new yorker
californian now
um and and being there the people are
salt of the year like can you imagine
what if he thinks that way about
about nashville can you imagine what he
thinks about jackson wyoming
so i i just find it very uh very
irrational as gnome does when people
criticize what's done with your work and
and
you put so much out there um do you ever
get scared
like retroactively what's going to
happen based on something you might have
said a few years ago or is it like
you you just assume that someone's going
to misconstrue what you do
or do you allow yourself to learn like
maybe you'll write a thing maya culpa i
was wrong
um you know i can't see jerry doing that
but how do you handle the
the kind of entropy of of these kinds of
being so public because
it's very daunting to me i think i think
it's a lot of good points so
i have a uh you know starting from from
the beginning of what you were saying
i don't like to hit publish and i've
we've talked about this before i don't
like to hit publish unless i'm a little
bit afraid or a lot afraid of what
people will think
of me and of the piece because again
uh if if you're not a little bit afraid
then you're not saying something new
like if i was just writing new york's
going to come back because it's got
grit and resilience everybody on the
street is saying that
and it's not new they don't need my
extra voice like so my
energy and efforts i'm not trying to say
something controversial but i should say
something
that i research and have a unique
opinion on and so but having a unique
opinion
you know if you're going to stick out
like a nail you're going to get hammered
and so
that's going to happen if you're if
you're truly afraid
of something you're doing then it means
you're doing something new that's never
been done before because
you're going into the unknown and but i
don't do it just for the sake
of doing it as some have accused me i
just don't write unless i have an
opinion
that hasn't been written before i
otherwise i'll just spend time
reading and learning and experiencing
and experimenting and coming up with
new material and just like
just like i'm not gonna tell a joke
about pop tarts when i do stand up
because oh
jerry seinfeld's done that you know
rosie o'donnell back and i'm not this is
this is all well known back in the 70s
when they were all performing in la by
the way were
jerry live for 30 years uh when rosie
o'donnell was at performing at um
um i i forgot the name of the it might
have been the comedy store
but uh yeah one of those places
and uh she was known for copying jerry
seinfeld's jokes
okay that's you're not doing anything
new so you're not really making
a stake for yourself in comedy like
jerry seinfeld's
known in comedy because he carved out
his own unique voice
dave chappelle has his own unique voice
george carlin had his own unique voice
richard pryor
was the first one to really talk
autobiographically about the hardships
he went through and how he made it funny
so these are
the these are people who said who who
did who went into the unknown they said
things they were afraid to say
and became known for it so that's i
think that's the key for for writing for
art for
look even for science right you're going
to by the nature of it you have to go
into the unknown and that's how you risk
you risk everything when you go to the
south pole with a
you know huge telescope the bicep two
and you're looking to see
gravitational waves past the
cosmic microwave background radiation
you're taking a risk you might not see
anything
might not come back right yeah yeah you
might not come back and but you're also
you know having a because it's so
unknown and so interesting you're taking
also a chance for you know greatness and
the nobel prize and
seeing the the birth of the universe and
so
the uh you know experimenting and and
going outside your comfort zone and and
going into the unknown whether you're an
artist a scientist a politician
economist
this is important yeah and again i don't
think i think
seinfeld obviously is an expert at that
with television and comedy
jon stewart was good at that with mixing
comedy and and news and politics
same with bill maher whether you agree
with them or not it's they're good at it
and for me i've been writing about these
types of issues for
20 years and but i do it in a very where
i
go into the unknown and where i started
going into the known many years ago is i
always weave it with personal stories
and that gets it very
emotionally charged and i i have had
backlash before
never quite like this but we're also in
the time unprecedented which is sort of
making my point actually that this time
is different
and again i think
it would have been it's better if people
with such a platform and influence like
like jerry seinfeld he can write in the
new york times op-ed
i wrote to the new york times yesterday
and i said let me do a rebuttal they
never responded to me yeah
new york times he's got that platform
there's many things he can do with it
other than attack me yeah and look i'm a
big boy i could
handle it it was upsetting and
distressing for like a few hours
yesterday
and then i got over it and also i wrote
a rebuttal
people saw the rebuttal and were very
positive and encouraging
overwhelmingly and uh you know because
they saw where i was coming from and it
was a good
place and and like you mentioned before
i've in general throughout this pandemic
i've been coming
from a good place and trying to to help
people maybe this was a little bit more
emotionally charged with a little bit
more negativity than i usually have
because
i have a little more uncertainty here i
don't think so james i mean actually
this this reminds me of uh something
that's really delightfully
serendipitously connected to the way
that you and i met and that's your
article from june on
also on linkedin 12 secrets of
persuasion i learned from eminem
and you start that off with i walked out
of the tedx conference 20 minutes before
my talk and i was planning on just going
to the airport
and flying home i'm a quitter i was
terrified i did not want to give this
talk
my plan was to go home and never return
any angry calls from the organizers
and you and i talked when you came when
you were gracious enough to come on my
podcast last time i was like
i was kind of the opposite like i was
like this is my time i'm going to do it
the moment you know like the eminem song
but um but also but and then like i was
even defusing it and my mother-in-law
came and said
are you nervous to speak it was 2 000
people there
and i was like i wasn't nervous until
now now that you make me think about it
and she felt horrible and i was just
like no i'm just kidding mom but um
but you write in this article and i saw
and i don't know if it was intentional
or not
but you weave through your article on
linkedin about new york city dead
forever
with some of these things like you
presage the criticisms that your enemies
are going to level at you
you have you you start with negativity
bias
you know because and you talk about all
these things and but in the linkedin
article about eminem this
the secrets that you learned from eminem
these are persuasive secrets
that are in his bat rap battle with baby
or whatever his name is i still haven't
seen that but uh
but thankfully you wrote this you wrote
this uh great post with a with a youtube
link as well
and that's a great scene i know it's
just so awesome you go through all the
biases and you talk about the in-group
bias
and and you start with that and you're
was that intentional because you start
with like i'm a new yorker
in-group bias boom i read that first
herd behavior what are all these people
going to do
here's like the collective how they're
reacting to it number three
availability cascade there's so many
things happening there's so much data
people are leaving and you just lay out
the data boom distinction bias out group
bias
people like you don't have to live in
new york to get great food
there's going to be other places that
spring up there's going to be
opportunity bias there's ambiguity bias
how do you know like
what actual aspect of this uh pandemic
afflicting new york city is going to be
most pernicious
we don't know it's ambiguous um
credential bias you're talking about how
you started off
what your stakes are you own a half of a
comedy club you share a part owner of a
comedy club
uh stand-up new york which is a great
you know it's seinfeld talks about it
he's been there you have stakes in this
your daughter goes to college there
you're from there you would love to go
believe me i know you the little i know
of you
you would like to go back to new york
city if it was just like virus is gone
you'd be out of florida in a minute it's
not like oh i need that but it's not
just a virus it's the reaction to the
virus and i think that's what you're
speaking about
and that's why it's so perplexing but
it's not surprising that they would
publish what he wrote
yeah and i um but you know it's it's
funny because
and then i also answer all the
objections like yes people will say
this is like the 70s no it's not so i
answered you know this is another thing
in the eminem
thing where he he he before the other
guy starts rapping he says
i am white i am a bomb i live in a
trailer with my mom my boy future is
uncle tom you have a
dumb friend named cheddar bobby you go
through all this and you say all the
objections so like was that part of this
article like was that intentional or is
it just the way your brain works now
yeah i didn't consciously think about it
but that is how
i think about about these articles i
always try to
have a miniature arc of the hero inside
even a very
non-fiction type of a narrative and
um and you know these things all belong
in you know all these biases happen in
the arc of the hero
and uh because you know like
you know a big criticism of of let's say
a piece of fiction
or or an art and even a nonfiction story
is the deus
ex machina where just some lightning
from the sky comes
and saves the hero well people that
people will object to that so you can't
do that uh
you have to address that in the story
that through his own in
or her own ingenuity the hero survives
and it's the same thing the same kind of
cognitive biases have to be
addressed in any article except for an
academic article
right yeah right if i lead off with i am
a i'm a
bum right but but you know i
i do wonder if you know it seems like
because this was so charged and i was
trying to have the
in group bias like i'm a new yorker
there was a there was a desperate
attempt to somehow label me not a new
yorker and i don't even know how that
right started other than the fact like
okay for a week or two i've been in
florida but i was the other 52 years
i've been in new york
so and all through the pandemic so i
don't know how i got labeled i don't
want some non-new
some guy from iowa telling me what to do
like right
you know i got a video last night
somebody's like
you know threatening me like i don't
want some non-new yorker coming here and
telling me my city's dead
like you know and threatening me and um
and you know i again uh uh
you know i think it's i think there's
going to be
hopeful things like i think the country
will change it's it's like
the economy is not up or down right now
it's tilted and
how the you know the water instead of
going down one stream
has gotten you know started going down
other streams i don't know what how you
say like things that split off from a
stream but
tributaries tributaries yeah so there's
other tributaries now
flowing into some of these second and
third tier cities by the way this is
something that's been written about for
the past few months i'm not the first to
say
it so you know i guess maybe just me
saying it all together
and then i had a strong title but people
were critical of the title but
if i didn't have the title nobody would
have clicked on it and there's real
danger that the title is is truth and
uh i don't know i don't know what to say
i don't think i would have done anything
differently
and i i did do another article saying
look here's the hope is that
you know opportunity gets dispersed and
decentralized
and then i did you know i had to do the
robot a little seinfeld so i kind of
more clearly laid out
the issues without as much of the the
story and
uh so i it was a little calmer and
you know but you may have a point
earlier though that uh people are kind
of
going in and out of different lanes like
i've spoken to a lot of scientists
during this pandemic and like you
wouldn't have given me
advice on hydroxychloroquine for
instance but
i've seen i've talked to epidemiologists
i've talked to
other types of doctors i've talked to
virologists immunologists
i've talked to all sorts and one thing i
have noticed
is that some scientists who have the md
you know the initials in front of them
or after them
they do kind of veer out of their lanes
a little bit and with a little bit of
research i could see
oh this guy doesn't really know anything
more
than anybody else uh you know
particularly if they weren't an
epidemiologist
right you know like that's what i always
say james when somebody asks me like i
give a talk about cosmology
it'll be to a big audience um a popular
not a university lecture
given what do you think about climate
change
i don't like you know okay and i always
preface it by saying
i hope when you invite uh someone to
speak about um you know oceanography
and atmospheric chemistry that when you
ask them what do you think about
different ways the universe could have
begun that they say uh please consult a
cosmologist
you know so it's like yes i understand
differential equations newton's laws
quantum mechanics etc
uh but there's more to being an expert
you know
i mean theoretically what dirac used to
say paul dirac nobel prize winner
discovery of the predictor of
anti-matter essentially
advanced quantum mechanical dynamics
he said you know my equations describe
all you know
um all of chemistry and most of phys you
know
and then he would say things like
biology is just applied chemistry but
it's
it's very you know i don't think you
want you know by that logic
and medicine is just applied biology so
do you want dirac who could barely tie
his own shoelace do you want him to do
brain surgery on
i mean so this is this authority bias
halo effect that's another bias that
comes in yeah
and and because i had you know like
einstein they wanted him to be the
president of israel
for and he was just like what the heck
you know um or you know i wouldn't go to
einstein for like
fatherly advice he basically abandoned
his kids he had sex with his cousins or
something
i forget exactly the the details but but
the bottom line is
like we have this halo effect around
scientists which is why andrew coleman's
saying like
you should listen just to scientists no
you should listen to scientists but you
we
voted for you andrew cuomo um as or the
new yorkers did or david newsom here in
california
because you have to make the hard
decisions not outsourcing
yeah and let me ask you a question
though like like one
i i i agree with you but i'm i'm curious
if you could broaden
what your expertise is in the sense that
yes
you have answers to you know
cosmological
questions but also my guess is you're
better at asking questions
regardless of the field so if someone
said to you
what's the answer about climate change
you might not know the answer
but you might be able to say well here's
10 questions i would think about asking
if this was my field
absolutely that you could do with some
expertise because questions
are just as hard as answers in many yeah
i get asked for example i get asked and
i see different things because i'm not
an expert in that field i'll give you an
example
uh because i'm not an expert in
oceanography i'll sometimes be asked to
review proposals about like physical
oceanography and in fact once it came
down to
reviewing a proposal about why is there
a difference between the melting rate of
the north pole versus the south pole
ice caps there should be identical just
based upon irradiation and other factors
there's some current effect but the
scientists you know i won't say who it
was
but they couldn't get funding because
you know it kind of was disagreeing with
some of the orthodoxy of what their
field had suggested was the truth
and so the only way they could get is
sort of like a private entity
um affiliated with with uh the
university i was at
and so i would read about it and i'd
understand it but because i wasn't so
invested in the field i didn't have that
sunk cost
into like the narrative of my field um
that i could see things from a different
perspective and ultimately was able to
persuade people that you know it wasn't
like it was like 50k or something
it wasn't tremendous amount of money for
by scientific standards to support
students and
go on a vessel or whatever but um but he
ended up getting it
and and good good did good work
interesting work um
but when the stakes there's a difference
when stakes are really high and that can
happen actually occur in my field you
know like
we said we discovered the origin of the
universe in a huge
you know cataclysmic event called
inflation um that had huge implications
and actually on the very day that we
announced the results and
now that i describe in losing the nobel
prize my book i'll plug it now
um uh we actually had people on like
atheists saying this proves there is no
god
and then we had this is the proof of the
handiwork of god like on the same day
you know for eminent scientists or
theologians or scientists theologians
uh and it's just so funny that even in
that thing where it's where
it should be the most objective data
here are gravitational waves which
are indicative of a of quantum
perturbations in a primordial scalar
field blah blah blah
there could be like what gets layered on
top the super
the super structure that then gets
erected around it is really dramatic i'm
actually reading
galileo's book the dialogue uh the
dialogue and the two world systems which
fascinating book it's not only you know
and it made me think i keep thinking
back
it's still stuck in my craw when you
gave these awesome tips on how to read a
non-fiction book
and talked about these crappy signs no
no no you talked
like like how do you read it and um and
there's a there's a preface to it
that says most books like newton's
principia one of the most influential
books of all time
is basically unreadable i mean even by
me i can hardly understand it i've seen
the original copy i've read translation
i can't get past the first couple pages
the dialogue
is written and as a as a dialogue it's a
platonic conversation between two
three people and it's so engaging it's
400 years old almost
and you're just like you're wrapped up
and this guy had this amazing ability
to do the hardest thing that you always
talk about if you can tell a story
you've got it made it doesn't matter if
you're a salesman you're running a
website you're doing copy editing
you have a skill and you stress this
often
uh and uh but part of the problem is
most scientists don't think that that's
a value so you ask me like
can i talk about client yeah i could
talk about i can talk about like the you
know quantum mechanical
properties of of of drugs you know like
if you don't use zinc if you know people
are saying oh zinc is just like
only used in diaper rash ointment well
that's not really true like
there's a lot of medicines that you take
um for like lupus
that have uh arsenic in them like okay i
thought arsenic kills you you know like
you know so just to say oh zinc is only
used for diaper rash
that's that's a fundamentally an
irrational objection now i'm not
make taking a stand because i actually
haven't studied it um i do think you
know people using it around the world
for
50 years or whatever at least we know
it's safe it's not going to kill now
some people heart condition anyway i'm
not a doctor of that
variety but getting back to it i think
most scientists can't tell a story
um uh really in the way that their
subject matter is the greatest subject
matter there is
and that storytellers are doing such a
poor job at it
which is why i feel like my mission is
kind of like make things interesting the
way joe rogan does
about science that's really passionate
and uh but but you know explain the work
of my colleagues who are more brilliant
than i am
but are not as good at maybe telling a
story or weaving together the threads
that's what i see my mission is
um and while i'm also trying to do real
science well let me ask you this like
richard feynman is obviously one of the
greatest physicists ever
yeah part of the reason why i think he's
one of the greatest businesses ever
because i have no clue really
is because he writes such compelling
stories like surely you're joking mr
feynman is maybe the most popular
modern science book around like for the
past 50 years
and you know and then also you have kind
of these um string theorists like
you know brian greene and michio keku
who uh
who have popularized science look neil
grass tyson i don't know if he's a good
scientist or not but he's a good
storyteller so he's one of the most
well-known scientists at least
and i think he's the well-known most
well-known scientist in human history
because of
just the advent of media etc like yeah
and
scientists have been known by more
people on the face of the planet maybe
stephen hawking
yeah maybe einstein yeah yeah hawking
was really good at it but he was also he
had that
wit he had that he didn't take himself
so seriously and it's very hard james
when you talk about
a pandemic that can kill millions of
people or global warming which you know
some say will
render the earth uninhabitable and kill
everybody you know it's hard to make
light of that like
let's you know here's 10 jokes on the
way the world will end you know by
by fire by ice etc uh those kind of you
know things are not endemically
you know uh just hilarious you know gut
busters
but uh but you're right these people
have a skill and the hard thing is to do
that and continue to do real science and
that is a little bit rare brian green
does that exceptionally well
you know neil degrasse tyson will say
he's not currently and actually he does
a great thing
if you ask him oh tell me about the big
bang neil you're so smart he'll say go
talk to well he won't say go talk to
brian keating he doesn't return my
emails or
calls but uh maybe someday he will um
not when he finds out that you know i
talk to you and and that you're
you know ransacking uh new york city
where he calls home and makes his living
but i've been on his podcast a couple of
times he's been on mine but
that was that much i much that was then
that was when new york city was vibrant
right now i'm not allowed to go back to
new york city there's like a picture
airport yeah yeah it's like by the way
if you're coming to new york my friends
there now
you know working on you know the
university system that you talk about
i mean you're just giving facts you're
saying here are all the dorm rooms that
are going to be unused here
and like what are the yeah of course the
kids aren't going to pay dorm you know
fees
they're going to be remote they're going
to pay tuition at a lot of places
uh but the landlord's going to how are
you going to stay afloat comedy clubs
like jerry's like oh you comedy club
blah blah blah
like um i heard it said that and i think
you told me this
you know most the average american has
500 saved to their name
uh what would you say is the average
amount that the average comedian has
saved up
probably less than 500 negative yeah i
know uh
uh and this is i i don't say this in a
um happy way i know a very good comedian
very talented
maybe one of the most talented in the
world actually and one of the most well
known
if i were to say his name and during
this
time he's been delivering for grubhub
like
you know it's just his skill was kind of
a physician
james i know a neonatologist i know like
she works in an icu she she was doing
grubhub
both for financial reasons because they
laid off doctors right we laid off our
essential work some essential workers
people don't talk about that
she had to make a living and she's you
know she's single she made a good living
they furloughed her one day a week
that's a huge thing when you have
built-in expenses and it's not like the
ppp or whatever was called
covered all that but the other thing is
she also missed social contact and she
missed seeing people and even
you know she's single and so she she
couldn't you know she couldn't meet
people and
it wasn't like you know she's going out
and it's like tinder in real life or
something but
she wanted to just have human contact
and i think that's what's missing
and and i think you know how much longer
can this go on you come to new york city
now
you have to quarantine for two weeks or
you get like a ten thousand dollar fine
like
has there ever been a like after 9 11
they didn't let me get too close to
ground zero but you could get very close
to it actually for a couple of days
you could walk through it and it was
dangerous i didn't do that i came around
early november of 2001 but um
it wasn't like you had a quarantine when
you came there for two weeks i mean
what's that going to do
no i know and that's why again this time
is different and so it's a different set
of
questions like okay they took the
economic playbook of 2008 2009 which is
the federal reserve reduces interest
rates to basically zero
they they they start what's called
moving up the curve instead of just
buying treasury bills they buy other
types of
bonds um this is all economic stuff
so but they it's basically they followed
that playbook but to a little bit more
of an extreme
and uh and then there was also of a
keynesian style stimulus package passed
by congress
but then nothing else about this is
the same as any other event not world
war ii not the depression not
the 70s it's different and also then you
have like these nuances like
the fact that bandwidth is pretty good
like we could
you know we could have meetings with
people now and then
be more productive we could have meeting
after meeting and and and then go back
to work without
moving or or we could jog around the
block or there's a lot
there's a wide variety of options now
for us to get our work done
and it's just it's just a different
world and that and that has to be
acknowledged
but also the economic problems of
you know what's happened has to be
acknowledged again i
i i keep saying it and i and maybe it's
because it's still
like i i can't it still bothers me i
really
don't know why i got i wish i hadn't
gotten so much
hate and uh i think james you know you
did
again you know i'm going to give you
your own advice you know doctor here
myself dr altucher
you know what you do is so rare and you
have to think about it
how many people have the platform to do
something that requires courage like
me saying something to you i've got you
know a few thousand followers
it doesn't take that much i actually
tweeted out to you know jerry i was
gonna say something
tell me if you think this is funny like
you know jerry refuses to come on
college
he's so brave i tweeted out you know he
attacks james altitude
but he's too scared to come on college
campuses and i was going to put unlike
the old days where he used to go on high
school campuses to find his future
uh partner anyway i didn't go that way
that's funny i didn't go that d i
but like let's say i did you know like i
was a little nervous i'm not gonna say
that you know maybe jerry
jerry's not going to see what brian
keating what the hell he doesn't care
about that
but um yeah i didn't publish it anyway
but you know but it took no courage not
to do that because i don't have any
backlash from jerry seinfeld's not going
to come down on me
but i think what you're doing again you
did it for pure reason if you did it to
like
you know you're gonna sell you know uh
shares in your in your timeshare in
southern florida wherever you are now
i think that's another story but i
personally know like jerry's not like
making fun of joe rogan is he he's not
making fun of you know like people
has twice read my article on the air
yeah
it's it's just unbelievable and and you
know and so like you didn't do it for
ulterior motives i know you you're doing
it for for purity
you give away so much and and you still
have
you know have this uh extreme a
degree of of of courage but i'm just i
think
it's too soon to tell you know like they
used to ask cho and lai
you know in vietnam like what do you
think of the french revolution
in the 1970s and cho and lai said too
soon to tell
and i think it's too soon to tell you
know about about the revolution of this
article look
we all want to get back to new york city
i can't wait to go there i've got some
friends
family investing you know kind of i was
thinking about buying in a you know a
you know and renting a pier a tear there
someday if i if i could afford it just
because i love it so much and i miss my
family there so much i mean my brother
my cousins i don't know right now if i
could do it and
and part of me was just like i'm just
torn between all this
and you know for me to think about
that's the way that
um new york i didn't say like i hate you
james for bringing it up
i said this is this is very courageous
and so
again i don't don't second-guess it it's
it's had a lot more goodness
the fact that you're getting the
attention look what again would jerry so
if i wrote to the san diego union
tribune you know new york's dead like
no but he went right back and blasia
wouldn't care but you're making them
think and they have to confront you
and if they don't let you responding
kind i think that that's
you know almost proof like you did you
did the final thing you did from the
eminem
um you know kind of uh what do you want
to call debrief take down
analysis that you did about his
persuasive techniques at the very end of
the article and at the
very end of the m m article you talk
about the
reciprocity bias or um you know what you
call the ben franklin effect
which is you know ben franklin used to
use a technique to win over his
political enemies
he would ask them to borrow a book from
his political rival
his his rival would give him a book and
then uh then the rival would think hmm
now i'm the type of person that gives
ben franklin
books so i must have this fondness for
ben franklin and it
completely uh alternated his view about
ben franklin at the end of your article
or at the end of your statements to
jerry you're like you're welcome back
you know like come on back jerry you
know will he do it
i think it's proof that he won't i think
it's proof that uh
that he doesn't have the courage that
you have anyone can write that i mean
could
the point is could you write jerry's
article james could you steal man
no well i could i mean you could do it
like brian keating writes like florida
sucks
like could you write you know could you
write an account you know could you do
with jerry seinfeld in other words just
defend new york grit
resilience platitude here insert you
know uh
i can't do exactly that but i could do
because that wouldn't quite steal man
like you said that was
an ad hominem attack no i don't mean
that i just mean could you write an
article about how great new york is
going to come back and pla
and not attack personally because that's
not your style but you could write an
article that's hopeful
resilience grit blah blah blah yeah so
if i was
jerry seinfeld or anybody so this is a
great exercise
so this the steel man exercise or
charlie munger calls this
inverting which is you have to argue the
other before you may have an opinion
you have to argue the other side better
than even then
your opponents can argue it so let's say
i was trying to argue the other side of
my
article i don't even want to say better
than jerry seinfeld
because there's like five levels higher
to argue this
but i would say this look a lot of it's
going to boil down
to the relationship between
our the mythology of new york city with
the mythology of
america it's obviously they're connected
new york city's
not only the financial capital of
america it's really like the capital of
the world in some ways
and uh let's look at it in terms of the
election
if biden wins he's going to certainly
bail out
uh new york city now would is 10 billion
dollars
enough no that's a band-aid you still
have to
issues with are people going to leave
are people going to uh
you know are these broadway actors going
to move to nashville or wherever
so maybe you need a little bit more than
10 billion maybe you need 20 billion
then you also need to um temporarily
give new york city enough money to give
corporate incentives
for companies to come back or or huge
incentives for them to stay and maybe
even
hire more employees like give them tax
incentives the more employees they
they hire um and and that and then you
have to argue that's going to happen so
if biden's elected that will happen and
if trump is reelected
you could say look trump's a lifelong
new yorker he wants to come in as savior
uh dinkins is on his way out so
you know at that point trump's not quite
a lame duck but
uh cuomo could possibly take credit if
he works out a deal with trump to bail
out new york city
new york city needs money that's it's a
financial issue
to keep people in then it needs to
create incentives to keep people and
companies
in there right now because people are
leaving like like you call any moving
company they're overbooked they don't
even return the phone calls
so i sent you that article from the new
york like or are they
like we're turning away business yeah
exactly so
so that's how i would steal mana is that
the likelihood is i can make an argument
that the likelihood
is is that there will be a bailout of
some sort now and i didn't address that
in my article because that
that i don't know if that will happen
that's very a lot of uncertainty but
i could see a path towards that
happening but the bailout would have to
be
massive and much more massive than they
they
have their hand out for so but i could
be wrong too it
could could be maybe not as massive
because of this resilience
and and so on but you know that's how i
would steal man it i would say
james brings up good points let's
address them one by one
and that's how answering the objections
and then i would say look okay
uh uh restaurants we should provide
incentives maybe for
uh you know new york residents and
tourists like hey let's do a deal with
tourists like
if you come now you get um 100 of meals
for free
at the airport or or something i don't
know like but there should be
some game of incentives that's played
and that's how i would steal man the the
argument
so in the last couple minutes that we
have um james you know if you could
rewrite it
redo it um what would you do differently
uh would you go even more in the data
side i
i i really like that you have this you
know data
backed up and it's it's actually not too
dissimilar i mean there used to be
i was reading again galileo's dialogue
book um and it's just so
funny you know in 1632
these guys are going back and forth you
know newton had leibniz who he hated
uh actually galileo as funny enough he
sabotaged
in some sense his own freedom because he
um he there were uh data points from
kepler
that could have added weight to the
copernican
theory that the sun is the center of the
universe that was what galileo was
arguing about
in his book called the dialogue on two
world systems the two world systems are
aristotelian
earth-centered geocentrism where the
earth is the center of the universe
and then um and then copernicans
heliocentric where the sun is the center
of the universe
well kepler had this phenomenal data
that went back to
um that went back to tycho brahe and
others
with his rival you know he got his nose
cut off and a duel
with a scientific rival or you know
political rifle so you know things have
calmed down somewhat we we settled
things nowadays with you know fist
fights and
and faculty club but uh but now galileo
basically ruined his some of his own
support because
kepler had these data points and kepler
according to galileo was this uh
basically this fraudulent grifting
astrologer you know he had such derision
for
he wouldn't even show him his telescope
so he like kept it to himself so
what would you do differently uh about
this article if anything
or you know would you add more to it
because i think it's such a powerful
and such a powerful piece i mean i could
have added more to it but it was already
very long
so uh i didn't want to add that much
more to it it was it was
it was one of my longer articles but
uh you know first off let me ask you why
are you reading
um galileo i think that's very
interesting oh so i'm uh participating
in a
uh book club this uh prager university
which i did a
very popular um course on you know kind
of a five-minute video it's not a real
university you're like
well can you be on something that's not
a real university i'm like i once went
to budweiser university to get a beer
you know like give me a break
um but anyway i did one about the
multiverse
um and why so many scientists have
almost like a
religious like faith in it and it got a
lot of attention and he
you know from scientists and
non-scientists people can check that out
on youtube or elsewhere
um but uh but now they want to do a
course on the classic books of all time
so thing like 1984
um victor frankel's man searched for
meaning so they wanted to have something
in the scientific realm
and something that influenced me as a as
a professional scientist
was galileo's book the dialogue because
it's really a work of popular science
it's a it's a work uh that has
tremendous imp impact
on kind of the uh the battle between
science and religion
politics and science but it also is a
you know psychology
study in this man galileo and it's
fascinating to see
what his um what his desires his
compulsions
his biases the original title for that
book tell me you know if you do a b
testing which is better
the dialogue on two world systems
or on how tides on earth work
i might like to talk on two world
systems actually that's what it was
called
and but originally galileo wanted to
call it how tides work or something like
that which i didn't know
uh until i started rereading this book
and i'd forgotten it
but everyone knows it's the book that
got him in trouble eventually got him
imprisoned and he was you know
in some sense on trial for reason you
know some people he was in prison for
for for being rational and there are all
these myths about him
um that you know he went to jail and was
torture all this stuff some of which i
actually
actually you know included my tedx talk
which you may or may not remember
actually you were about on your way to
the airport i think i was vomiting then
uh
so um so i'm reading because it's a
study in psychology so just like you
have with eminem
i want to do kind of a breakdown like
what is a scientist like
what what makes a scientist what drives
him or her
the biases the humanity because this
this vision that like
a scientist is einstein i'm not einstein
therefore i can't be a scientist that's
detrimental to progress in science so
those are the reasons i'm rereading this
book and the reason i ask is
i think it's a very important aspect of
mastery and learning
to read the history of your field
like i'm always amazed for instance
you know in like let's say you know when
i used to be a professional
investor how many of my peers did not
know
the history of investing the history of
bubbles the history of
the different economies i know a lot of
people now who
don't really know you know you know
pundits or investors or
economists or people who write about
these things don't really know how the
depression started how it ended how
they don't really know the roots of the
great recession i did a whole kind of
what i call a twitter master class on it
and people were uh
amazed that they didn't really think of
it in these in these ways but
it reminds me of how bobby fischer one
time when he was a kid
he uh so he was the greatest chess
player ever arguably
and at one point he took a year off when
he was like 12 years old 13 years old
and he disappeared for a year and during
that year
he read he studied every single game
played in the 1800s
you know so there was all these classic
players and they had a very different
style of playing then it was called the
romantic style of playing chess but it
was it was considered very basic by
the time fischer was was around and but
what he did was he
studied these eight games from like the
1830s so much that he found
improvements in every game and then he
came back played in the u.s championship
all of these
ancient openings that people were like
oh this is just easy to
and he had improvements though and he
won like with a perfect score the u.s
championship and became the youngest
chess grandmaster in history and so
studying
the the ancients and studying the older
material really does
build in any field this kind of you know
mastery of the the fundamentals and
people kind of forget that i think
i try to teach that to my students
actually on the final day of their
defense hopefully none of them are
listening they're all hard at work
in the lab but uh but i asked them
things like uh i
you're a professional astronomer now or
astrophysicist now you have phd doctor
so and so
um i think the earth is not only flat
but it's also stationary
prove me wrong and sometimes even my
colleagues in the room can't answer how
do we know that we don't now
now that transports you back to the time
of galileo so the reason he wanted to
call
the book the how tides work was because
he felt that was the most convincing
evidence
for the motion of the earth around the
sun which is the tenant central tenet of
copernican theory
that he was trying to espouse and
support uh
and he used as evidence for it this uh
this
you know mug of vodka my my irish up
coffee over here so he said you know you
have coffee and it sloshes around and
there you can barely see it
and that's because it's wrote the earth
is rotating on its axis like this
but it's also going around so just like
the coffee in this cup
sloshes around as it goes so to do the
tides
and that was his theory and the catholic
church forbid him
from calling it that and thank goodness
that it they did
and then he basically had to rewrite it
and and and that became lesser known
as one of the pieces of evidence because
we and it's good for him it turned out
really well for him to listen to your
editors
even when they have like swords and and
you know and and pitchforks or whatever
uh the rack and so forth uh my editors
are slightly more kind
uh they are sometimes right in that that
theory turned out to be completely wrong
the moon causes the tide has nothing to
do with the earth's motion around the
sun
at all zero nada zilch fs nada whatever
and so he was prevented you know we
wouldn't even know about it
if he had used the original title that
he wanted it wouldn't have had the
impact
it probably maybe never would have
gotten published maybe they wouldn't
have been
as famous as he was because other people
around the same time were coming up with
the same theories but he stood out
because of his
the book his personality his
imprisonment his fights with the church
exactly the legend the story
as you keep bringing up the story
resonates so loudly that the forward
written to that book is by albert
einstein
and he even talks about the edition that
i have uh you know where he writes the
forward to that
to the translation that you know yeah
great men can have great flaws basically
is is the thesis that that we come up
with from reading einstein's forward
and he even talks about like how they
knew what they knew but
think about what you just said to be a
great painter
i believe you should go back and first
paint every great painting in history
just reproduce it oh it's beneath you
you've got these great ideas for like
doing whatever fine you can have those
ideas but first
understand it and the problem with
things like the nobel prize the
influence that the nobel prize has
that's pernicious in science
is that it teaches you the answers
before you have the questions like it
teaches you
here's the right answer einstein here's
our answer direct schrodinger
but you never go through the process
like what if i was in 1631
and i wanted to prove i get teleported
back and this famous example that gives
you night terrors
you know if james gets teleported back i
mean you have very few skills you've
admitted i have slightly more because i
you know i can divine and make
predictions about each other i would
kill myself as soon as i got a toothache
what am i going to do like the poorest
person you know that we know
you know has better dental care
hopefully than the richest you know
king of england did in 1632 but how
would you how would i prove it how would
i prove that the earth
and surprisingly as i said you know look
at this picture behind me
like manhattan looks pretty flat new
york looks pretty like the earth looks
pretty flat
prove it wrong and that was your brain
that's a hard question i ask people all
the time can you prove that the world is
not flat and they're like oh come on the
world
everyone knows no one can prove it it's
very hard oh they'll say go into space
and i'm like no no you're in 1632.
like there is no spaceship like you're
going to tell the king of england to go
into a spaceship
so i agree with you a hundred percent
this this underappreciated kind of
masters
of western and um you know and even in
eastern civilizations um they they had
great technology
reproduce those and it's just like
training your jokes i you know you could
probably do
really good job in comedy maybe you know
we talked about this once before
but like just like telling seinfeld's
joke whatever
like see if you would do it differently
like see if you get a laugh if you don't
get a laugh but he got a laugh why is
that
and no that's a that's a really good
point like i said to my
daughter once um she was thinking of
going
to do an open mic and i said okay take a
bunch of seinfeld's jokes
and i and and try them and i said
and she said isn't that stealing and
stealing is a big no-no in company
which i agree with that no no like if
you're performing in front of
professionally in front of an audience
do not steal anyone's jokes but i said
to her no it's like you're doing
a cover and the only other audience is
beginning comedians that open mic
so you're just doing a cover to you're
isolating
what people think is the key um
component of comedy which is the joke
and you're getting everything else
correct so we know the joke is funny so
now we have to master
stage presence crowd work uh your
nervousness
the way you hold the mic you know all
your likability your charm on the stage
so let's see if you can get if you can
get those going then you could start to
write your own
material and it's it's it's like just
doing a cover of a joke
and seeing if you could do a good job i
don't i've never
done that because i went straight for
better or for worse to the the stage but
i'll do it in my home
i will imitate in front of a mirror like
dave chappelle
or jerry seinfeld or you know
whoever my favorite comedian of the day
is like
you know i've had hundreds of favorite
comedians so i will i will imitate them
until i've got their style down
and then i don't tell their jokes on
stage but at least i know
oh here's a situation that tj miller
once found himself in and he did this
i'll try to do something similar and so
you build up this vocabulary of
you know techniques built through
history yeah you had a podcast with
like the most funniest joke it's about
like state abbreviations or whatever
like
oh yeah gary goldman man yeah that is a
brilliant joke right so
one thing you get just directly is now
you can imitate like if you work on
impressions which are very hard to do
perfect you know well
but um you know you can get their voice
like did you ever notice like whatever
you could actually
literally imitate jerry or whatever and
get their accent
so like you would you would actually be
building something new in your
repertoire even though it's
derivative of what they did and of
course yeah i mean like the marvelous
mrs maisel is kind of based on that
like her husband that becomes her ex you
know it's like copying jokes from
i don't know bob newhart or somebody
yeah right
dave chappelle of his time maybe but the
uh the interesting thing to me is like i
noticed this with my students um i'm
i'm really lucky i get students from all
over the world that come here i'm
students from china
from thailand i had students from uganda
from kenya and with the graduate
students i had i would pay out of my own
pocket because the university for some
reason doesn't value this
but i would pay for them to go to
toastmasters and what do you think they
do there they're like
you know doing a toast a roast or
whatever they don't know
like whatever they're talking about like
eisenhower at the rose garden in 1952
yeah whatever
they're just reading stuff but they have
to then they they get these meta skills
a presentation
of a crowd warming up invaluable it's
extremely valuable and we never teach it
and maybe next time we chat um because i
know you have to go i've kept you over
but we'll talk um we'll talk some other
time about uh academia and i want to get
your
kind of i'd love to know i've asked this
of you know noam chomsky eric weinstein
um some non-jewish people too i've asked
them
what would they teach at their
university so if altitude university
comes to fruition as i'm hoping it will
and and i'd like to be the first dean
provost chancellor of that
fine institution but i want to know what
would you what kind of things
encapsulate the sum of human knowledge
of of you know and it could be things
like speaking
comedy you know art et cetera so let's
save that
hopefully you'll yeah that's a great
topic and it could be divided into two
which is
what's good from um you know first
through twelfth grade and then what's
good
uh as an adult yeah because there's
different skill sets
yeah you know that are needed and and
actually i'd also like to kind of uh
just thinking about it
uh think about which which of these
things require if any
um in person presence or which can we
actually use in the
in the virtual environment and uh things
like virtual reality etc i want to get
your
impressions about that um and then we'll
have uh we'll have you know bill de
blasio and jerry seinfeld come in and
talk about politics
oh my god i i wonder if i just were to
call
bill de blasio right now and like i'm
going to do this as an experiment
actually yeah let's do it
i'm going number oh let's see call his
office exclusive live i got it yeah
let's do what if i do this
no i don't do i mind come on do it okay
um let's see the mayor's office
uh new york city bill de blasio uh
office of the mayor
uh let's see contact the new york city
government
uh
[Music]
let's see it's one of those things where
oh okay here we go
contact the mayor by phone
212 new york who who who
who knows what new york is now like the
numbers like do you know what the
numbers are is that do they have it
you know now it's like the middle digits
of pi you know that's the only way i can
remember it
no they have it now on the phone so
that's good so it's new is 639
n-e-w they make it look like a math
problem now
um nine six i have no idea what i'm
gonna say to him if he
if he if he comes on but we'll figure it
out
r k so i'll have to
um i'll have that one part of the
headphone off okay no problem
so it's recording
i'm gonna hit zero they're just talking
to me about alternate side parking
that's really relevant
okay music of ringing
oh somehow i picked chinese
man that's why new york city's falling
apart
i wish i could hook this up to the phone
oh yeah if it's jay around jay could do
it for us and he could translate chinese
just kidding
i'm gonna try i'm gonna try calling it
again i'm gonna try it again i must have
accidentally hit some number
so if he picks up i'm just gonna say
listen
i want to help you you're trying to help
them out
alternate side parking
can i get that in tagalog please
press one
coronavirus help yeah you're trying
food delivery press two
report a tropical storm
if you need the citizens of the very
popular
cause press three
unemployment benefits for
property tax expert five
air conditioners press six
nothing no looting riders or anything
like that nothing like that
well that's a 911
am i calling about alternate side
parking no
[Music]
please connect me with mayor bill de
blasio's office
to send an email
invite him on your show that's what we
have to do
speak to a 3-1-1 representative
yes
it's really hard to get to the mayor
that's by design
yes please yeah can i be connected to
his office please i um
i recently wrote excuse me
uh yes please submit a comment for me
comment is james altucher
alt uch
er would like
would like to speak to him about
jerry seinfeld's letter and uh sorry
jerry seinfeld's article
and mr sun and mr altucher's article
i'm on hold
you're inviting him to come on your show
to discuss
this that's a good idea
maybe they're trying to put me through
gotta put on speaker if he picks up
oh yeah how do i do that i wonder
where the speaker is must be
james altucher alt
u-c-h-e-r
altiture alt uch er
gmail.com
203 512-2161
no i i am james altucher
the mayor just tweeted to you
um 2211
broadway new york city new york
come on hold again okay
does that have a speaker um yeah i
wonder
how i put the speaker on
oops
if he answers i mean if somehow i get
through to him which seems unlikely yeah
i'll ask him to
i'll just say hey let me in
yeah no no sorry
yeah you'd like to volunteer to to help
with the
reopening plan for comedy clubs for
restaurants
oh yeah you employ how many people do
you employ in new york city
your business owner homeowner voter
okay thank you very much
okay so there's basically no way
to get a hold of him i had to submit a
comment in 50 words or less
and he'll get back to me within two
weeks and under no circumstances should
i call the number again about the same
topic
that's very uh you know it's like new
york is just so welcoming i mean i i
forgot about that
well if there's any way like i could
just call up like i'm friends with the
brooklyn bro president so i could just
call him on his phone and
he's coming on my podcast next week to
talk about my article but i guess de
blasio is not as
uh accessible well yeah i mean that's
eric adams right
yeah yeah he's great i love him uh so
hopefully he'll be the next mayor who
knows but
yeah yeah actually you could you could
say when you write him this 50 word
thing you know you
want to give equal opportunity eric
adams uh and you
to come on the show to talk about this
article instead of just you know
tweeting about it you're a businessman
you own
and employ people uh own real estate you
employ people
and uh you're trying to do you trying to
help new york and that's the bottom line
and i don't think there's anything wrong
with that i think you're you're
tremendously
uh courageous as i said and uh i really
you know
i really have a fond spot in my heart
for you james it's always fun to talk to
you
yeah ditto brian i'm looking forward to
chapter two of when we talk about how
the universe began i'm i'm all ready
i've got it yeah i can't wait till i get
back in my lane that's all i want to do
is
swim in my lane down the east river over
that's over here uh james awesome to
chat with you thank you so much be
strong be courageous
there's millions of people that support
you all over the world uh keep doing
what you're doing
uh thanks brian i i appreciate it and i
appreciate always coming on the show and
and thank you so much we'll talk soon
bye james
see you